hey there are you exploring test
automation
are you wondering why everyone is
talking about selenium around you do you
want to know what selenium is all about
if yes this is the video for you simply
lawn brings to you a very simple
tutorial on selenium what should you
expect from this video before you start
understanding any automation tool it's
good to look back into what manual
testing is all about what are its
challenges and how automation tool
overcomes these challenges challenges
are always overcome by inventing
something new so let's see how selenium
came into existence and how did it
evolve to become one of the most popular
web application automation true selenium
suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components so we
will look into each of them and as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
looking at what the advantages are and
the limitations of selenium and how do
we work around those limitations all
right so let's get started manual
testing a definition if you can say a
manual testing involves the physical
execution of test cases against various
applications and to do what to detect
bugs and errors in your product it is
one of the primitive methods of testing
a software this was the only method
which we knew off earlier it is
execution of test cases without using
any automation tools it does not require
the knowledge of a testing tool
obviously because everything is done
manually also you can practically test
any application since you are doing a
manual testing so let's take an example
so say we have a use case you are
testing say a facebook application and
in facebook application let's let's open
the facebook application and say create
an account this is your webpage we
choose under test now now as a tester
what would you do you would write
multiple test cases to test each of the
functionalities on this page you will
use multiple data sets to test each of
this fields like the first name the
surname
mobile number or the new password and
you will also test multiple links what
are the different links on this page
like say forgot an account or create a
new page so these are
the multiple links available on the web
pages also you look at each and every
element of the webpage like your radio
buttons make your drop-down list
apart from this you would do an
accessibility testing you would do a
performance testing for this page or say
a response time after you say click on
the login button literally you can do
any type of tests manually once you have
this test cases ready what do you do you
start executing this test cases one by
one you will find bugs your developers
are going to fix them and you will need
to rerun all this test cases one by one
again
until all the bugs are fixed and your
application is ready to ship now if one
has to run test cases with hundreds of
transactions or the datasets and repeat
them can you imagine the amount of
effort required in that now dart brings
us to the first demerit of the manual
testing manual testing is a very
time-consuming process and it is very
boring also it is very highly
error-prone why because it is done and
nearly and human mistakes are bound to
happen since it's a manual executions
testers presence is required all the
time one is to keep doing manual steps
step by step again all the time he also
has to create manual reports group them
format them so that we get good-looking
reports also send us reports manually to
all stakeholders then collection of logs
from various machines where you have run
your tests consolidate all of them
creating repositories and maintaining
them and again since it's all is a
manual process there is a high chance of
creating manual errors that scope of
manual testing is limited for example
let's say regression testing ideally you
would want to run all the test cases
which you have written but since it's a
manual process you would not have the
luxury of time to execute all of them
and hence you will pick and choose your
test cases to execute that way you are
limiting the scope of testing also
working with large amount of data
manually is impractical which could be
the need of your application what about
performance testing you want to collect
metrics on various performance measures
as a part of your performance testing
you want to simulate multiple loads on
application under test and hence
manually performing these kind of tests
is not feasible and to top it all up say
if you are working in an agile
we're code is being churned out by
developers testers are building their
tests and they're executing them as and
when the bills are available for testing
and this happens I turret of Li and
hence you will need to run this test
multiple times during your development
cycle and doing this manually definitely
becomes very tedious and burning and is
this an effective way of doing it not at
all so what do we do we automate it so
this tells us why we automate one for
faster execution 2 to be less
error-prone and 3 the main reason is to
help frequent execution of our tests so
there are many tools available in the
market today for automation one such
tool is selenium birth of selenium much
before selenium there were various tools
in the market like say rft and qtp just
to name a few popular ones selenium was
introduced by gentleman called Jason
Huggins way back in 2004 he was an
engineer at ThoughtWorks
and he was working on a web application
which needed frequent testing he
realized the inefficiency in manually
testing this web application repeatedly
so what he did was he wrote a JavaScript
program that automatically controlled
the browser actions and he named it as
JavaScript test Runner later he made
this open source and this was renamed as
the selenium Koch and this is how
selenium came into existence and since
then selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool for testing web
applications so how does selenium help
so we saw all the T merits of manual
testing so we can save by automation of
test cases one selenium helps in speedy
execution of test cases since manual
execution is avoided the results are
more accurate no human errors since your
test cases are automated human resources
required to execute automated test cases
is far less than manual testing because
of that there is a lesser investment in
human resources it saves time and you
know time is money its cost effective as
selenium is an open source it is
available free of cost early time to
market since you save effort and time on
manual execution your clients will be
merrier as you would be able to ship
your product pretty fast lastly since
your test cases
our automated you can rerun them any
point of time and as many times as
required so if this tool offers so many
benefits we definitely want to know more
detail about what selenium is selenium
enables us to test web applications on
all kind of browsers like Internet
Explorer Chrome Firefox Safari edge
opera and even the headless browser
selenium is an open source and it is
platform independent the biggest reason
why people are preferring this tool is
because it is free of cost and the qtp
and the rfp which we talked about are
chargeable selenium is a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate the
automation of web application as I said
it is not a single tool it has multiple
components which we'll be seeing in
detail in some time and all these tools
together help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform it is platform
independent why because it is primarily
developed in JavaScript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge so selenium has
this record and replay back tool called
the selenium IDE which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
you can replay the script back however
this is mainly used for demo purposes
only
because selenium is such a powerful tool
that you should be able to take full
advantage of all its features
selenium provides support for different
programming languages like Java Python
c-sharp Ruby so you can write your test
scripts in any language you like one
need not know in-depth or advanced
knowledge of these languages also
selenium supports different operating
systems it has suppose for Windows max
Linux
even Ubuntu as well so you can run your
selenium test on any platform of your
choice and hence selenium is the most
popular and widely used automation tools
for automating your web applications
selenium set of tools so let's go a
little more deeper into selenium as I
said selenium is not a single tool it is
a suite of tools so let's look at some
of the major components or the tools in
selenium and what they have to offer so
selenium has four major components one
selenium ID
it's the
simplest tool in the suite of selenium
it is integrated development environment
earlier selenium IDE was available only
as a Firefox plug-in and it offered a
simple recorded playback functionality
it is a very simple to use tool but it's
mainly used for prototyping and not used
for creating automation in the real time
projects because it has its own
limitations like any other record entry
Plato selenium RC this is nothing but
selenium remote controller it is used to
write web application tests in different
programming language what it does it it
basically interacts with the browser
with the help of something called as RC
server and how it interacts is its uses
a simple HTTP POST get request for
communication this was also called a
selenium 1 dot over sure but it got
deprecated in selenium 2 dot o version
and was completely removed in 3 dot o
and it was replaced by webdriver and we
will see in detail as why this happened
selenium webdriver
this is the most important component in
the selenium suite it is a programming
interface to create and execute text
test cases it is obviously the successor
of the selenium RC which we talked about
because of certain drawbacks which are C
hat
so what webdriver does is it interacts
with the browser's directly unlike our
see where the RC required a server to
interact with the browser and the last
component is the selenium grid so
selenium grid is used to run multiple
test scripts on multiple machines at the
same time so it helps you in achieving
parallel execution since the selenium
webdriver with you can only do
sequential execution grid is what comes
into picture where you can do your
paddle execution and wise parallel
execution important because in real-time
environment you always have the need to
run test cases in a distributed
environment and that is what grid helps
you to achieve so all this together
helps us to create robust web
application test automation and we will
go in detail about each of this
components so before that let's look at
the history of selenium versions so what
did selenium version comprised off it
had an ID RC and grit and as I said
earlier there were some disadvantages of
using RC
so RC was in its path of deprecation and
webdriver was taking its birth so if you
look at selenium to version it had an
earlier version of webdriver and also
the RC so they coexisted from three-dot
onwards RC was completely removed and
webdriver took its place there is also a
four dot worsen around the corner and it
has more features and enhancements some
of some of the features which are talked
about a w3c webdriver standardization
improved ID and improved grader now
let's look at each of the components in
the selenium suite selenium IDE is the
most simplest tool in the suite of
selenium it is nothing but an integrated
development environment for creating
your automation scripts it has a record
and playback functionality and it's a
very simple and easy to use tool it is
available as a Firefox plug-in and a
Chrome extension so you can use either
of this browser to record your test
scripts it's a very simple user
interface using which you can create
your scripts that interact with your
browser the commands created in the
scripts are called Cellini's commands
and they can be exported to the
supported programming language and hence
this code can be reused however this is
mainly used for prototyping and not used
for creating automation for your
real-time projects why because of its
own limitation which any other record
and replay tool has so a bit history of
selenium ID so earlier selenium IDE was
only a Firefox extension so we saw that
IDE was available since the selenium
bortion one selenium IDE died with the
Firefox version 55 that was ID was
stopped supporting from 55 ocean on one
and this was around 2017 timeframe
however very recently all new brand
selenium ID has been launched by apply
tools and also they have made it a cross
browser so you can install the extension
on Chrome as well as as an add-on on
Firefox browser so they completely
revamped this IDE code and now they have
made it available on the github under
the Apache 2.0 license and for the demos
today we'll be looking at the new ID now
with this new ID also comes a good
amount of features
reusability of test cases better
debugger and
most importantly it supports paddle test
case execution so they have introduced a
utility called selenium side runner that
allows you to run your test cases on any
browser so you can create your
automation using IDE see on Chrome or
Firefox but to command prompt using your
side runner you can execute this test
cases on any browser
thus by achieving your cross browser
testing control flow statement so
initially in the previous versions of
idea they were control flow statements
available however one had to install a
plug-in to use them but now it has made
available out of box and what are this
control flow statements these are
nothing but your if-else conditions the
while loops the switch cases so on
it also has an improved locator
functionality that means it provides a
failover mechanism for locating elements
on your web page so let's look at how
this ID looks and how do we install it
and start working on that
so for that let me take you to my
browser so say let's go to the Firefox
browser so on this browser I already
have the ID installed so when you
already have an ID installed you will
see an icon here that says selenium ID
and how do you install this you simply
need to go to your Firefox add-ons here
where if it says find more extension so
just type in selenium ID and search for
this extension so in the search results
you see the selenium ID just click on
that and now since I've already
installed here it says remove otherwise
for you it is going to give you an Add
button here just click on the Add button
it will install this extension once it
is installed you should be able to see
this selenium ID I can here okay so now
let's go ahead and launch this ID so
when I click on that it is going to show
me a welcome page where it's going to
give me few options the first option is
itself record a new test case in a new
project so straight away if we choose
this option you can start recording your
test case in which case it's going to
just create a default project for you
which you can save it later then open an
existing project so you can open if
you're already for have a saved project
create a new project and close so I
already have an existing project with me
for the demo purpose so I'll go ahead
and open that
open existing project and I have created
a simple script what the script does is
it logs me into the Facebook using a
dummy user mean you're sorry user name
and password that's all it's a very
simple script with few lines and this is
what it is going to do so what we will
simply do is we just run the script and
see how it works for that I am just
going to reduce the test execution speed
so that you should be able to see every
step of execution here all right
so what I'll do now here is I just
adjust this window and I just simply say
run current test all right so I just get
the side-by-side so that you should be
able to see what exactly the script is
great okay so now you are able to see
both the windows ok so now it's going to
type in your user email here there you
go
and now it'll enter the password and it
has clicked on the login button so it's
going to take a while to say login and
since these are the dummy IDs
it does you are not able to log in here
and you're going to see this error
window fine that is what is the expected
output here now on the ID if you look
here after I execute the test case every
statement or every command which I have
used here is color coded in green so
that means this particular step was
executed successfully and then here in
the log window it will give you a
complete log of this test case right
from the first step till the end and
your end results in it says FB login
which is my test case name completed
successfully let's look at few
components of this ID the first one is
the menu bar so let's go to our ID all
right so the menu bar is right here on
the top so here is your project name so
either you can add a new project here or
rename your project so since we already
have this project which is named as
Facebook and then on the right you have
options to create a new project open an
existing project or save the current
project and then comes on toolbar so
using the options in this toolbar you
can control the execution of your test
cases so first one here is the recording
button so this is what you use when you
start recording your script and then on
the left you have two options here to
run your test cases the first one is run
all tests so in case you have multiple
test cases written here you can execute
them one by one
sequentially
by using this run all tests else what
you can do is if you just want to cut
run your current test this is what you
would use then ID has this debugger
option which you can use to do a step
execution so say for example now
whenever I run the scripts it's going to
execute each and every command here
sequentially so instead if I just select
the first command and say do step
execution alright so what it does is the
moment it finishes the first command
which is opening of Facebook right I
think which is already done here yeah
all right so once this is done it is
going to wait immediately on the second
command and it says paused debugger so
from here you can do whatever you would
like to do in case you want to change
the command here you can do that you can
pause your execution you can resume your
execution here right you can even
completely stop your test execution or
you can just select this to run the rest
of the test case so if we say run the
test case what it is going to do is it's
just going to simply go ahead and
complete the come complete the test case
now there is another option here which
is you see the timer there which is test
execution speed so to execute your test
cases in the speed you want say whenever
you are developing an automation script
right and say you want to give a demo so
you need to control the speed some time
so that the viewer is able to exactly
see all the steps which is being
performed and this gives you an option
to control that complete execution right
so do you see the grading here
so we have somewhere from fast to
completely slow execution so the
previous demo which I showed was I
control the speed and then I executed it
so that we could see every command how
it is be executed all right so what's
the next this is called as an address
bar so whichever wherever whenever you
enter in URL here that is where you want
to conduct your test and another thing
what it does is it keeps it history of
all the URLs which have used for running
your test then here is where your script
is recorded so each and every
instruction is displayed here in the
order in which you have recorded the
script and then if you look here you
have something called as log and
reference so now log is an area where it
records each and every step of your
command as in when they get executed
right so if you see here it says open
HTTP
bucum and okay so that means this
command was executed successfully and
after the complete test case is done it
gives you whether the test case passed
or fit so in case there is a failure you
will immediately see this test case is
filled in red color also there is
something called as reference here for
example say if I click on any of this
command the reference tab what it is
going to show me is a details of this
command which I have used in the script
it gives you the details of the command
as well as what the arguments have been
used or how how is that you need to be
using this particular comma okay so now
what we'll do is let's go ahead and
write a simple script using this ID so
that this you'll get an ideas how do we
actually record scripts and ID so for
that I have a use case here a very very
simple use case so what we will do is we
will open Amazon dotted then we'll
search simply search for say a product
iPhone and once we get that search page
where all your iPhones are displayed we
will just do an assert on the title of
the page simple alright so let's do that
so first thing what I need is an URL
okay so first let me go to my Firefox
browser here and say Amazon dot it so
why I'm doing this just to simply get
the right URL absolute URL path here and
so that I don't make any mistakes while
typing in the URL okay so I got this so
let me close all this windows I don't
need any of this let's minimize this
alright so here what I will do in the
tests tab I will say add a new test and
learn name this test as Amazon search
done I'll say add now I'll enter this
URL which I just copied it from my
browser and then I just say start
recording so what it did was since I've
entered the URL in this address box it
just opened the Amazon dot in your air
now let's do our test case so in my test
case what I said was I want to search
for iPhone once I have this I'm just
going to click on my search button so
now this gives me a list of all I phones
and then I said I want to add an
assertion on the title of this page so
for me to do that what I do give me an
option is have to just right click
anywhere on this page and you see the
selenium ID options here so in this I
will select assert title and then I
would close the
Krauser so that kind of completes my
test case so now take a look at all the
steps which is created for me so it says
open / because I've already provided the
URL here so either you can replace it
with your regular URL or you can just
leave it as it is so what I will do
since this is going to be a proper
script and I might be using this to run
it from a command prompt also so I'll
just replace this target with the actual
URL and then what it is doing it is
setting of window size then there are
whatever I did on that particular URL on
that website it has recorded all the
steps for me so this is where it says
type into this particular text box which
is my search box and what did it type
iPhone this was the value which I
entered now there was one more feature
which I told you in this new ID which
had which I said it has a failover
mechanism for your locating techniques
now that is what this is now if you look
here this ID is equal to two tab search
text book this is nothing but that
search box where we entered the text
iPhone and it has certain identification
through which this ID identifies that
web element and dart has multiple
options to select that particular search
box so right now what it has used as ID
is equal to two type search box however
if you know the different locating
techniques you will be able to see here
that it has other techniques also which
it has identified like the name and the
CSS and the XPath so how does this help
in failover I'll say tomorrow if Amazon
dot in website changes the ID of this
element right you are not going to come
and rewrite the scripts again instead by
using the same script what it will do is
if this particular ID fails if it is
unable to find the element using the
first locator which is the ID it simply
moves to the next available ones and it
tries to search for that element until
one of this becomes true that is what
was the failure mechanism which has got
added it's a very brilliant feature
because most of our test cases break
because of element location techniques
well let's come back to this so then we
added an assert title right so what is a
sir title here it simply captures the
title of that particular page and it
checks this is all a very simple test
case so what we will do now is we will
stop the recording
then I'm also given a closed browser so
right now what I will do is I'll just
comment this out why because if I just
run this test case it's going to be very
fast and you might not be able to catch
the exact command execution what has
happened alright so right now I'll just
disable it so that it will just do all
these test cases and it just stays this
without closing the browser so now I
just say run the current testing so your
Amazon in is launched ok it was typed in
the iPhone it's also clicked on the such
so it is done so now if you look here
since we are in the reference tab it is
not able to show so let's go to the lock
and now let's see the lock so it's going
to be running lock so if you notice here
the previous examples which we have run
for Facebook is also in the same lock so
we all have to see the log from running
Amazon search because that's our test
case so if you see her every command
line it was executed successfully assert
title was also done and your test case
was executed successfully so it passed
now what we will do is on this assert
title I will just modify this and let's
say just add some text I just add double
s here now this by intentionally I am
going to fail this discus just to show
you that whenever there is a test case
failure how does the ID behaves and how
do you get to know the faders alright so
I just run the test test case again so
before that let's close the previous
window all right done and now here I'll
also uncomment the close because anyway
it's a failure which I'm going to see
which I should be able to see it in the
loss so I'll close the browser after the
execution of test case okay so let's
simply go and run the test case ok
Amazon dot an is launched it should
search for iPhone now yeah there you go
alright now it should also close the
browser yes it has closed the browser
and it has failed now see here now this
is the line where our command fit why
because the expected title was not there
and if you look in the logs it says your
assert title on Amazon dot
was something different and it did not
match with what we had a stood for so
this is how simple it is to use your ID
to create your Quatermain
and scripts so we saw all the components
of ID we saw that a card button then I
showed you the toolbar I showed you the
editor box and also the test execution
lock so now let's come to what are the
limitations of this ID with ID you
cannot export your scripts your test
scripts to webdriver scripts this
support is not yet at it but it is in
the works
data-driven testing like using your
Excel files or reading data from the CSV
files and passing it to the script this
capability is still not available also
you cannot connect to database for
reading your test data or perform any
kind of database testing with selenium
webdriver yes you can also unlike
selenium webdriver
you do not have a good reporting
mechanism with the ID like say for
example test and she earth report and
she so that brings us to the next
component of the suite which is selenium
RC selenium remote control so selenium
RC was developed by Paul Hammond he
refactor the code which was developed by
Jason and was credited with Jason as a
co-creator of selenium selenium server
is written in Java it is used to write
web application tests in different
programming languages as it supports
multiple programming languages like your
java c sha perl python and ruby it
interacts with a browser with the help
of an RC server so this RF save server
uses a simple HTTP GET in post request
for communication and as I said earlier
also selenium RC was called a selenium
1.2 over sure but it got deprecated in
selenium 2 dot o and was completely
removed in 3 dot o and it got replaced
by what webdriver and we'll see why this
happened and what was that issue which
we had with the RC server so this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
at a very high level so when Jason
Huggins introduced selenium you know the
tool was called as JavaScript program
and then that was also called as a
selenium core so every HTML has a
JavaScript statements which are executed
by web browser and there is a JavaScript
engine which helps in executing this
command now this RC had one major issue
now what was that issue say for example
you have a test script say test dot
JavaScript here which you are trying to
access elements from anywhere from the
google.com domain so
what used to happen is every element
which is accessible II are the elements
which can belong only to google.com to
me like say for example mail the search
or the drive so any elements from this
can be accessible through your test
scripts however nothing outside the
domain of say google.com in this case
was accessible say for example if your
test scripts wanted to access something
from yahoo.com this was not possible and
this is due to the security reasons
obviously not to overcome that the
testers what they had to do was there to
install the selenium core and the web
server which contained your web
application which is under test on the
same machine and imagine if you have to
do this for every machine which is under
test this is not going to be feasible or
even effective all the time and this
issue is called as the same origin
policy now what the same origin policy
issue says is it prohibits a Java Script
from accessing elements or interacting
with scripts from a domain different
from where it is launched and this is
purely for the security measure so if
you have written a scripts which can
access your google.com or anything
related to google.com these scripts
cannot access any elements outside the
domain like as we said in the example
yahoo.com this was the same origin
policy now to overcome this what this
gentleman did was he created something
called as selenium remote control server
to trick the browser in believing that
your course your selenium core and your
web application under test are from the
same domain and this is what was the
earlier selenium remote control so if
you look at again a high level
architecture or how did this actually
work first you write your test scripts
which is here right in any of the
supported language like your PHP or your
Java or Python and before we start
testing we need to launch this RC server
which is a separate application
so this selenium server is responsible
for receiving the Cellini's commands and
these Cellini's commands are the ones
which you have written in your script it
interprets them and reports the result
back to your test so all that is done to
your RC server the browser interaction
which happens through RC server right
from here to your browser so this
happens through a simple HTTP POST and
get
and that is how you RC server and your
browser communicate and how exactly this
communication happens this RC server it
acts like a proxy so say your test
scripts asked to launch a browser so
what happens is this commands goes to
your server and then your RC server
launches the browser it injects the
JavaScript into the browser once this is
done all the subsequent calls from your
test script right from your test scripts
to your browser goes through your RC and
now upon upon receiving these
instructions your selenium core executes
these actual commands as JavaScript
commands on the browser and then the
test results are displayed back from
your browser to your RC to your test
scripts so the same cycle gets repeated
right until the complete test case
execution is over so for every command
what you write in your JavaScript here
or your test script here goes through a
complete cycle of going through the RC
server to the browser collecting the
results again from the RC server back to
your test scripts so the cycle gets
repeated for every command until you're
complete test execution is done so RC
had definitely lot of shortcomings and
what are those so RC server needs to be
installed before running any test
scripts which is just so-so that was an
additional setup since it acts as a
mediator between your commands which is
your Cellini's commands and your browser
the architecture of RC is complicated
why because of its intermediate RC
server which is required to communicate
with the browser the execution of
commands takes very long it is slower we
know why because every command in this
takes a full trip from the test script
to your RC server to the core engine to
the browser and then back to the same
route which makes your overall test
execution very slow lastly the API is
supported by RC are very redundant and
confusing so RC does have a good number
of APs however it is less object
oriented so they are redundant and
confusing say for example say if you
want to write into a text box how and
when to use a type key command or just a
type command is always confusing another
example is some of the mouse commas
using a click or a mouse door both kind
of you know almost providing a similar
functionality so that is the kind of
confuse
which developers used to create hence
selenium RC got deprecated and is no
more available in latest selenium
versions it is obsolete now now to
overcome this shortfalls webdriver was
introduced so while RC was introduced in
2004 webdriver was introduced by Simon
Stewart in 2006
it's a cross-platform testing platform
so webdriver can run on any platform
like say Linux Windows Mac or even if
you have a upin to machine you can run
your selenium scripts on this machine it
is a programming interface to run test
cases it is not an ID and how does this
work actually so test cases are created
and executed using web elements or
objects using the object locator and the
webdriver methods so when I do a demo
you will understand what this webdriver
methods are and how do we locate the web
elements on the web page it does not
require a core engine like RC so it is
pretty fast
why because webdriver interacts directly
with the browser and it does not have
that intermediate server like the RC hat
so each browser in this case what
happens is each browser has its own
driver on which the application runs and
this driver is responsible to make the
browser understand the commands which
you'll be passing from the script like
say for example click of a button or you
want to enter some text so through your
script you tell which browser you want
to work with say chrome and then the
chrome driver is responsible for
interpreting your instructions and to
execute it on the web application
launched on the Chrome browser so like
RC web driver also supports multiple
programming languages in which you can
write your test scripts so another
advantage of F driver is it supports
various frameworks like test ngj unit
and unit and report ng so when we talk
about the limitations of webdriver you
will appreciate how this support for
various frameworks and tool help in
making the selenium of complete
automation solution for web application
so let's look at the architecture of
webdriver at a high level what is in
webdriver so webdriver consists of four
major components
the first one is we have got client
libraries right or what we also call it
as language bindings so since selenium
supports multiple language and you are
free to use any of the supported
languages to create your automation
script these libraries are made
available on your selenium website which
you need to download and then write your
scripts accordingly so let's go and see
from where do we download this so if I
go to my browser
so selenium HQ dot org right so if
you're working with selenium this
website is your Bible
so anything and everything you need to
know about selenium right you need to
come here and use all the stabs here in
this website so right now what we are
going to look at is what are those
language bindings so for that I'll have
to go to this download tab here okay and
if you scroll down here you will see
something like selenium client and
webdriver language bindings and for each
of the supported language of selenium
you have a download link right so say
for example if you are working with Java
here what you need to do is you need to
download your java language bindings so
let's go back to the presentation so
this is where your language bindings are
available next so selenium provides lots
of aps for us to interact with the
browser and when we do the demo I will
be showing you some of this APs right
and these are nothing but the rest ApS
and everything whatever we do through
the script happens through the rest
calls then we have a JSON wire protocol
what is jason javascript object notation
it is nothing but a standard for
exchanging data over the web so for
example you want to say launch of web
application through your script
so what selenium does it it creates a
JSON payload and post the request to the
browser driver that is here and then we
have this browser drivers themselves and
as I said there is a specific driver for
each browser as you know every tool has
its own limitation so does selenium so
let's look at what these limitations are
and if there are any workarounds for
them cannot test mobile applications
requires framework like APM selenium is
for automating web application it cannot
handle mobile applications mobile
applications are little different and
they need its own set of automation tool
however what selenium provides is a
support for integrating this APM tool
which is nothing but a mobile
application automation tool and using
APM and selenium you can still achieve
mobile application automation and when
do you usually need this when your
application under test is also supported
on mobile devices you would want a
can ISM to run the same test cases on
web browser as well as your mobile
browsers right so this is how you
achieve it
the next limitation so when we talked
about the components of selenium I said
that with webdriver we can achieve only
sequential execution however in real
time scenario we cannot just live with
this we need to have a mechanism to run
our test cases parallely on multiple
machines as well as on multiple browsers
so though this is a limitation of
webdriver
but what selenium offers is something
called as grid which helps us achieve
this and we will see in shortly what the
selenium grid is all about also if you
want to know more details as how do we
work with the grid how do you want to
install that grid so do check out our
video on simply learn website on
selenium grid third limitations so
limited give the reporting capability so
selenium webdriver has a limited
reporting capability it can create basic
reports but what we definitely need us a
more so it does support some tools like
say test Energy Report energy and even
extent reports which you can integrate
with selenium and generate beautiful
reports powerful isn't it also there are
other challenges with selenium like
selenium is not very good with image
testing especially for the ones which
are designed for web application
automation but then we have other tools
which can be used along with selenium
like Auto eight and Sakuni so if you
look at all this selenium still provides
a complete solution for your automation
need and that's the beauty of selenium
and that is why it makes the most
popular tool of today for automation
okay let's do a quick comparison between
the selenium RC and the webdriver
so RC has a very complex architectures
you know why because of the additional
RC server whereas due to direct
interaction with the browser webdriver
architecture is pretty simple execution
speed it is lower in RC and much faster
in webdriver
why because in webdriver we have
eliminated that complete layer of
selenium server right that the RC server
and we establish a direct communication
with
the browser through browser drivers it
requires an RC server to interact with
the browser's we just talked about it
and whereas webdriver can directly
interact with the browser so RC again we
talked about this as one of the
limitations that we have lot of
redundant APs which kept developers
guessing as which API to use for what
functionality however webdriver offers
pretty clean ApS to work with RC did not
offer any support for headless browser
whereas in webdriver you do have a
support for using headless browsers
let's see the webdriver in action not
now for the demo we will use this
particular use case and what this use
case is is navigate to the official
simple own website then type the
selenium in search bar and click on it
and click on the selenium free daughter
training so we are basically searching
for selenium 3 dot or training on the
simple own website first let's do the
steps manually and then we will go ahead
and write the automation script so let's
go to my browser on my browser
what are those are let me first launch
the simply learned website
okay and here what my new scale step
says is I need to search for selenium
and click on the search button so once I
do that it is going to give me a
complete list of all kind of selenium
trainings which is available with
simpler and what I'm interested in is
the selenium 3 dotto training here once
I find this on the web page I need to go
and click on that all right so this is
all the steps which we are going to
perform in this use case ok now so for
writing the test cases I'll be using an
ID images Eclipse I have already
installed my Eclipse and also I have
installed selenium in this instance of
my Eclipse
alright so if you can see the reference
library folder here you will see all the
jars which are required for the selenium
to work next another prereq which is
required for selenium and that is your
driver files now every browser which you
want to work with has its own driver
file to execute your selenium scripts
and since for this demo I'll be working
with the Firefox browser I will need a
driver file for Firefox now driver file
for Firefox is the gecko driver which I
have already downloaded and placed in my
folder called drivers now where did I
download this from let's go ahead and
see that so if I go back to my browser
and if you go to your selenium HQ dot
website you have to go to this download
tab here in the download tab when you
scroll down you will see in something
like third-party drivers bindings and
plugins in this you'll see the list of
all the browsers which is supported by
selenium and against each of this
browser you will find a link which has
the driver files now since we'll be
using the gecko driver this is the link
where you need to go to and depending on
which operating system which you're
working on you need to download that
particular file now since I am working
on Mac this is the file which I'm using
if you're a Windows user you need to
download the zip file and unzip it so
once you unzip that you would get a file
called great co-driver for your Firefox
or a chrome driver for your Chrome
browser and then what you do is you just
create a directory called drivers under
your project and just place the driver
files here so these are the two prereqs
for your selenium one is importing your
jar files like this and then having your
drivers downloaded and keep them under a
folder where you can reference to ok so
now we'll go ahead and create a class I
already have a package created in this
project so I'll use this project and
create a new class well say create new
Java class and let's call this as search
training I'll be using a public static
void man and I'll click on finish so
let's remove this auto-generated lines
as we do not need them alright now the
first statement which you need to write
before you when you start writing the
rest of your code is what you need to do
is you need to define or declare your
driver variable using your class web
driver so what I would do is I'll say
web driver driver
done alright now you will see that this
ID is going to flash some errors for you
that means it is going to ask you to
import certain libraries which is
required by the web driver so simply
just go ahead and say import web driver
from orj dot open s Q dot selenium this
is the package which we will need all
right so you have a driver created which
is of the class web tracker and now
after this I'm going to create three
methods alright so first method I will
have for launching the Firefox browser
ok and then I will write a simple method
for searching selenium training and
clicking on it this is the actual use
case what we'll be doing and then third
method I'm going to write is just to
close the browser which I'm going to be
opening right so these are the different
methods which I'll be creating and from
the public static void main I will just
call these methods one after the other
ok so let's go ahead and write the first
method now my first method is launching
the Firefox browser so I'll say public
void since my return type is null or
there is no return type for this let's
call it as launch browser ok all right
now in this for launching any browser I
need to mention two steps now the first
step is where I need to do a system dot
set property ok let's do that first and
then I'll explain what this does I just
say system dot set property
so this accepts of key and a value pair
so what is Mikey here Mikey here is
webdriver dot gecko dot driver and I
need to provide a value so value is
nothing but the path to the Gecko driver
and we know that this gecko driver which
I'm going to use your is right here in
the same project path under the drivers
folder okay and that is what the path
which I'm going to provide here so here
simply I need to say drivers slash gecko
tripod GEC ko alright done and let me
close this sentence alright now since
I'm a Mac user my gecko driver
installable is just the name gecko
driver if you're a Windows user and if
you are running your selenium scripts on
the Windows machine you need to provide
a complete path to this including dot
exe because driver executable on your
machines is going to be Kiko driver dot
exe all right so just make sure that
your path which you mentioned here in
the system dot set property is the
correct path ok then the next thing what
we need to do is I need to just say
driver is equal to new Firefox driver ok
so this command new Firefox driver
creates an instance of the Firefox
browser now this is also flagging me
error why because again it's going to
ask me to import the packages where the
Firefox driver class is present ok we
did that now these two lines are
responsible for launching the Firefox
browser form so this is done so what's
my next step in the use case now I need
to launch the website simply learn so
for that we have a command called driver
dot get driver dot get what it does is
whatever URL you are going to give it
here in this double quotes as an
argument it is going to launch that
particular website and for us it's a
simple own website so what I do as a
best practices instead of typing or the
URL I go to my browser launch dart URL
which I want to test and I simply copied
come back to your Eclipse and just
simply paste it so this ensures that I
do not make any mistakes in the URL ok
so done so our first method is ready
where we are launching the browser which
is our Firefox browser and then
launching the simpler website now the
next method what is my next method in my
next method I need to give
third-string to search selenium training
on this particular website now for that
we need to do few things
what are those few things let's go to
the website again all right so let me
relaunch this let's close this okay let
me remove all this and let's go to the
home page first okay this is my home
page so as you saw when I did a manual
testing of this I entered the texture so
now since I have to write a script for
this first I need to identify what this
element is for that what I am going to
do is I'm just going to say right click
here and I'll say inspect element all
right now this element let's see what
attribute it has which I can use for
finding this element so I see that there
is an ID present so what I'm going to do
is I'm just going to simply use this ID
and then I just copy this ID from here
go back to eclipse let's write a method
first so I'll say public void and what
do we give the method name say search
training or just search alright now in
this I need to use a command called
driver dot find element by ID is what
I'm going to use as a locating technique
and in double quotes the ID which I
copied from the website is what I'm
going to paste here okay and then what
am I going to do on this element is I
need to send that text in the text which
I'm going to search for which is
selenium
so I'll just say send keys and whatever
text I want to send I need to give it in
double quotes so for that selenium so
this is done so now I've entered the
text here and after entering the text I
need to click on this button so for that
I need to first know what that button is
so let's inspect that search button okay
now if you look at the search button
other than the tag which is span and the
class name I do not have anything here
all right so what I can do is I can
either use the class name or I can write
an XPath since this is a demo which we
have already used ID locating technique
I would go ahead and use the XPath here
so for me to construct an XPath I will
copy this class first okay and then I
already have a CRO path installed on my
Firefox so I'll use the CRO path and
first test my xbox so I just say double
slash let's see what was that element it
has a span tag
okay so I'll have to use span and
at clasp equal to and I'll just copy the
class name here and let's see if we can
identify that element yeah so it is able
to identify so I'll just use this XPath
in my code so I'll go back to eclipse
now it's a driver dot find element by
dot XPath and the expert which I just
copied from Krupa is what I'm going to
paste here and what is the action I need
to do here I need to say click done so I
have reached a stage where I've entered
this selenium okay and then I have
clicked on the search button once I do
this I know that expected result is I
should be able to find this particular
link here selenium 3 rotor training ok
and I should be able to click on that so
for that again I need to inspect this
so let's inspect this selenium 3 dot all
right so now what are the elements this
has now this particular element has
attributes like it has a tag h2 then it
has got some class name and some other
attributes so I would again would like
to use a XPath here now this time while
using the XPath I am going to make use
of a text functionality so that I can
search for this particular text so I
will simply copy this I'll go to micro
path the tag is h2 so I'll say simply h2
ok and here I'll say text equal to and
this is the text which I copied I must
start that yes there so I'm just going
to add an S okay so let's first test
here whether it is able to identify that
element yeah so it is able to identify
so can you see your blue dotted line it
is able to show us which element it has
identified so I'll copy this XPath now
and let's go to my ID Eclipse so now
here what I need to do is I'll have to
again simply say driver dot find element
by dot X path and paste the XPath which
we just did and then again have to do a
click operation dot all right so
technically we have taken all the steps
of the use case and we have written the
commands for that now let's add an
additional thing here say after coming
to this page after finding this we want
to say print the title of this page now
what is the title of this page if you
just hover your mouse on this it says
online and classroom training
for professional certification courses
simply none so what I will do is after
doing all these operations I will just
print out this page title on our console
so for that I have to just do this
driver dot so let's do a sis out so I'll
say this out system dot out dot println
ok and here I would say let's add a text
here the page title is and then let's
appended with driver dot get title so
this is the command which we'll be using
to fetch the page title that now what is
the last method I need to add just to
close the browser alright so let me add
a method here I'll say public wild close
browser and it's a one single command
which I need to call I'll say driver dot
quit ok and then I need to call all this
methods from my public static void main
so I let me use my class name which is
this so I'm going to create an object
obj is equal to new class name and then
using this object first is I need to
call the method launch browser and then
I'll call the method search and then
I'll call the method close process that
so technically our script is ready with
all the functionality which we wanted to
cover from our use case now there are a
few other tweaks which I need to do this
and I'll tell you why I need to do this
now for example after we click here
right after we click on the search if
you observed on your website it took a
little while before it listed out all
the selenium trainings for us and
visually when you're actually doing it
you wait for the selenium 3 dot or
training to be available and then you
click on that now same thing you also
need to tell your scripts to do that you
need to tell your scripts to wait for a
while until you start seeing the
selenium 3 dot or training or it appears
on your webpage there are multiple ways
to do that in your script and it is a
part of overall synchronization what we
call where we use kind of implicit and
explicit kind of a ways now since this
is a demo for demo purpose what I'm
going to do is I am going to use a
command called thread dot sleep and I'm
just going to give an explicit weight of
say 3 seconds so you can use this mainly
for the demo purposes you can use a
thread dot sleep command
now this thread or slip commas needs us
to handle some exceptions so I'm just
going to click on add throws declaration
and say interrupted exception now same
thing I'll have to do it in my main
function also okay so let's do that and
complete it alright so this is done so
by doing this what am i doing I'm
ensuring that before I click on the
selenium through your training we are
giving enough time for the script to
wait until the web page shows this link
to the selenium tree auto training
that's one thing I'm doing all right
and also enough since you are going to
be seeing this demo through the video
recording the script when it starts
running it is going to be very fast so
you might just miss out saying how it
does the send keys and how did it click
on the search button for us to enable us
to see it properly I'll just add some
explicit weights here just for a demo
purpose so after entering the keys right
so what I'll do is I'll just give her a
simple thread dot slip here okay
so probably a three seconds or a two
seconds which should be good data okay a
three seconds wait should be good enough
here so that we should be able to see
how exactly this works on your browser
when we execute this okay now our
complete script is ready so what I'll do
is I'll just save the script and then we
will simply run the script so to run the
script I just say right click run as
java application okay it says asked me
to select and save I have saved the
script now so let's observe how it runs
okay the simple on calm the website is
launched
so the selenium text has been entered in
the search box
it has clicked on the search okay all
right so now it did everything whatever
we wanted it to do all right so since we
are closing the browser you are unable
to see whether the selenium three door
training was selected or not
however what I have given here is to
fetch the title after all these
operations were complete and if you see
here the complete operations was done
and we were able to see the page title
here okay so now what I will do since we
are unable to see whether it clicked on
the selenium 3.2 training or not I'll
just come and Tower the closed browser
or the command ok so we will not call
the close browser so that the browser
remains open and we
to see whether did it we only find the
training link or not okay so let me
close this window we don't need this
Firefox window closed on tabs and then
I'll just Exedy execute the script so
I'll say run as java application so save
the file
okay simply Lancome is launched so
search text is entered now it's going to
click on the search button yes
alright so we've got the search results
it should click on selling in theory
auto training and yes it is successfully
able to click on that alright so now
it's not going to close the browser
because we have commented on that line
however it did print us a title yeah all
right so this is a simple way of using
the selenium scripts selenium grid so
grid is used to run multiple test
scripts on multiple machines at the same
time with webdriver you can only do
sequential execution but in real-time
environment you always have the need to
run test cases in distributed
environment and that is where selenium
grid comes into picture so grid was
conceptualized and developed by Patrick
the main objective is to minimize test
execution time and how by running your
tests parallel so design is in such a
way that commands are distributed on
multiple machines where you want to run
tests and all these are executed
simultaneously what do you achieve by
this methodology of course the parallel
execution on different browsers and
operating system grid is pretty flexible
and can integrate with many tools like
say you want a reporting tool integrated
to pull all the reports from the
multiple machines where you're running
your test cases and you want to present
that report in a good-looking format so
you have an option to integrate such
report ok so how does this grid work so
grid has a hub and node concept which
helps in achieving the parallel
execution let's take an example say your
application supports all browsers and
most of the operating system like as in
this picture you could say one of them
is a Windows machine one of them is a
Mac machine and another one say a Linux
machine so your requirement is to run
the test on all supported browsers and
operating system like the one which is
depicted in this picture so what you
have to do is first thing is you
configure a master machine or what you
also call it as a hub
by running something called a selenium
standalone server and this talent
standalone server can be downloaded from
the selenium HQ website using the server
you create a hub configuration that is
this node and then you create nodes
specific to your machine requirement and
how are these nodes created you again
use the same server which is your
standalone selenium server to create the
node configuration so I'll show you
where the selenium server can be
downloaded so if we go back to our
selenium HQ website so you can see here
right on the top which is selenium
standalone server and this is the latest
version available so you just need to
download once you download this keep a
version of this one on your master
machine that is your hub and this should
also be present on your node machines
and there is a certain command which you
can use to install this server as a node
and as a master depending on your
configuration so once that is done you
have your master and your master on the
hub and the nodes created your master
can control on which nodes you want to
execute test now say if this is a Mac
machine this is an Windows machine
through your master or your hub you
control on which machine you want to
execute what tests then also you could
have a multiple combination of tests
like say for example smoke test to be
run on all this nodes that's the kind of
configuration you can create or a
certain component test to be run on say
only Windows 10 with an edge browser or
say regression test on Mac machine so
any such things whatever configurations
you have for your node what happens is
the hub picks the right node which
conforms to your requirements or the
configurations which you have set up and
then sends a command to the node to
execute those test cases on the node
everything is controlled through your
master machine only here what happens on
the node so once the node gets the
command from the master the node
actually runs all the test cases which
is it which it mean tends to run on the
specific browser which you have
mentioned in your configuration file so
this is a very high-level architecture
and how a grid works so if you want to
know more details of how the grid work
you can refer to our video on simply
learn all right again limitations
so what limitation does this grid have
now the first one it it has relatively
poor scalability compared to many modern
applications it is pretty static each
server is configured in advance with a
subset of required browser instances
available so if you want to wear it this
you will need to reconfigure so any
configuration tomorrow and any machines
you want to change it cannot be done
automatically you need to completely
reconfigure that node and then add it
back to the grid thirdly although it is
available to run on virtual servers it
is actually not designed as a cloud
native application and because of as a
result of this it isn't optimized to
take advantage of things like say
distributed storage or dynamic scaling
or even automatic failover so these are
some of the limitations of the grid
advantages of selenium speed and
accuracy of course since there is no
manual execution your test can run
faster and with grid it helps in
parallel execution and you can run or
execute large volumes of tests within a
very short timeframe let's take an
example say before just before the
release of your product say during the
last lap of your testing you find a bug
and of course it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and you want to
run all the test cases pertaining to
that area now can you imagine that if
you have to do this testing manually how
long it's going to take so by automation
you can achieve this in a very short
duration of time and it will also help
you release your product in time with
very minimal or absolutely no human
errors the second advantage it's an open
source so it's available free of cost so
anyone can download it and start using
it it supports wide spectrum of
programming languages we have been
seeing throughout this presentation it
is not restricted to any particular
programming language so whatever
language you are comfortable with you
have an option to use that and righty of
selenium scripts selenium has support
for almost all browsers and operating
system we also talked about headless
browser support so this helps you create
test cases once using any of the browser
and run them across all browsers and all
operating system thus saving you lot of
time from manual execution and helping
and achieving
very broad test coverage and we also saw
that really easy to use tool right so
you can check out all our videos and you
can is just a matter of time that you
can master the skill of writing your
automation scripts reusability of course
like any programming language it
provides you a mechanism to reuse your
code and avoid redundancy well again
let's see an overall what are the
limitations of selenium itself
now since selenium is open-source that
is one of the biggest advantage now
there is a little disadvantage which
comes with that and what is it you do
not have much technical support because
it's an open source code however there
are loads and loads of documentation and
forums available which you can
definitely refer to and selenium as we
said it is only for automating web
applications it cannot handle the mobile
applications or even the desktop
application however it does provide
support for integrating tools like APM
for mobile testing selenium is not very
good with image testing especially
designed for your web application tools
again we have tools like Auto it and
securely which can be integrated with
selenium selenium webdriver has limited
a limited prepotent capability but again
it does provide a support for
integrating tools like tests ng report
ng and extent report it does not have
test management capabilities it need not
write not one tool need not have each
and everything what is required but
there is always a way to integrate it so
selenium does provide a way to integrate
any of the test management tools
now since selenium supports multiple
programming language the developer of
test automation will require to have
some basic knowledge of any of the
programming language it supports to
write effective automation scripts right
so this you could look at it as an
advantage or SN disadvantage so overall
if you look at all this right selenium
still provides a complete solution for
our automation meat and that is why we
can still say that selenium is one of
the most popular tool used in the
industry today for your web application
automation all right key takeaways so
overall in this presentation we saw the
disadvantages of manual testing what
pushed us to look at automation and then
we saw one of the most power
we'll tool available today for
automating web application that is
selenium so we looked at different
components of the selenium what it
comprises all how does the grid help us
how does the webdriver work and also we
had a small demo on how to use the
webdriver and then as any other tool has
its own disadvantages and limitation we
did a deep dive into what kind of
advantage of selenium provides and also
what are the limitations and a
workaround for these limitations so
thank you very much for watching this
video I hope you like this video and do
look out for more videos from simply
learn on selenium thank you very much hi
there if you like this video subscribe
to the simply learn youtube channel and
click here to watch similar videos to
nerd up and get certified click here